hello so I'll talk about this work we
had at stock this summer joint with Punk
irritation Dmitry it also have a
follow-up work maybe it's online this
week it's also with Rob Robert so
finally get some application for this
abstract machinery that lent its dog the
upshot of the whole work is well it's in
the title so it's machinery where you
can start from lower about improved
complexity resolution lower bounds
normally easy to prove it is not
terribly difficult the machinery allows
you to derive more or less as a black
box lower bounds in monotone circuit
complexity typically considered
difficult to through lower bounds for
monotone circuits a said a lifting
theorem again that really works in the
uphill direction actually the downhill
direction why
monotone circuit lower bonds yield proof
completely over that's an old thing from
the 90s it's called monotone feasible
interpolation I think was mentioned in
the bootcamp so this work you could see
as proving a corny verse which is one
shown feasibly interpolation so I'll
just throw out an application maybe the
cleanest we can derive using this
machinery and that's to show a
exponential lower bound for some
monotone variant of the XOR Sat function
so have to be careful how do you define
more not a monotone version of XOR zap
and you have to be clever in order to
make it a monotone function here's the
definition so you first imagine listing
all possible X or constraint on n
variables let's say ternary XOR
constraints so for each triple of
variables you have an equation saying
very parity should equal 0 or 1 and
there are n cubed roughly many such
equation
so the input to my XOR shot will be a
subset of these constraints just given
by an indicator vector so the input is
for each row I pick whether I want to
include this constraint in my CSP or
leave it out so something like this
that's an input 2x or sat specify the
subset of them and I say that this
evaluates to true if the set is
unsatisfiable
so I say unsatisfiable because I wanted
to be a monotone function I want it to
be the case that if I flip a 0 to a 1 in
the input that means I'm adding an X or
constraint to my set can only turn the
function from false to true but that's
why I'm saying yes inputs or
unsatisfiable small detail just to make
the function monotone
so we can show an exponential lower
bound for X so sad
and it's interesting because exercise is
a really easy function so you know
Gaussian elimination can can solve it
for you in fact there are really
efficient algorithms for linear algebra
classical results and in particular X or
satis even in NC 2 so speedy parallel
algorithms so you could interpret this
as oh that's interesting it's a huge
monitor versus non monotone separation I
think the previous example the only one
I know of is a tardis function so that's
some function you define out of the low
wash these are functions for graphs and
to compute that you need to solve a semi
definite program so it's in P but we
don't know if better upper bounds for
this function well here's an even easier
function
to milk this a little bit more you can
also say that this is the first
exponential separation between monotone
circuits and more electrons span
programs over GF 2 so X or sad you can
compute with monotone span programs so
monotone also keep topically high but
Morgan Spann program complexity low the
other other direction Roberts work
handled so they're now separated in both
directions exponentially I guess I could
still say that another monotone versus
non monotone candidate is the perfect
matching function so widely conjectured
that you need exponential size monitor
circuits only a quasi-polynomial lower
bounded is known but even perfect
matching is it's not quite as it's in
randomized in C this is even slightly
better than that so yeah it's sold this
is this is interesting okay it's that's
one thing you can get out of this
machinery in fact we can prove submit a
lower bound over any field not just for
achieve two equations but for any field
okay so the way this project started out
just really so Dmitry was telling me
about a characterization of circuit size
in the language of communication
complexity and so this was roughly a
year ago and I hadn't heard about this
before which was surprising I guess we
all know about the characterization of
formula size in the language of
communication complexity namely
determinist protocols and cotton victors
and games the transfer of in the mid 90s
came up with a circuit version of this
maybe it's not well known I I wasn't
taught that I some deficiency in my
education I mean I blame Tony but it's
really important because at least to me
this mere characterizations are kind of
a conceptual breakthrough because it's
if you view these models from the right
perspective it kind of suggests a
lifting theorem to be proved I couldn't
imagine that such a thing could even
formulate a theorem in this direction
without seeing this kind of a top-down
characterization of circuits so I'm
going to make sure that nobody leaves
today without understanding this
rosboroughs characterization I'm going
to spend some time on it Prospero showed
is that monotone circuits are
characterized by the communication
analog of pls so here let's polynomial
local search is one of these classes of
total NP search problems including
machine complexity problems that's our
total because of the principle that
every dag has a sink and there's a
natural communication analog of that
what ross perot showed is i'll define
the communication version of this in a
minute but he sure that this
characterizes disposed a monitor and on
monitoring of this but for us the
monotone circuit complexity of a
function really the logarithm of is is
the pls communication complexity of the
mana don't caution the victors in game
so I mean already we have a
communication model it cries out what's
the query analog so that's how this
characterization suggests a lifting
theorem to be proved yeah let me define
communication pls and explore this this
characterization
so generally circuit complexity it's
just a general cost matrix again without
the monotonicity condition
so this Padme means that P versus NP is
just a question in communication
complexity okay so here's the definition
of a pls protocol I define it as a
solving a two-party search problem
so generally Alice gets an input from X
Oh get some people from Y and they need
to find some output symbol that
satisfies this relation so it's just a
general search problem you can think
concretely of Moret unclutch movies and
games if you want so a protocol consists
of a set of vertices so maybe this set
it's a fixed set and each node here is
labeled with a candidate solution and an
associated communication protocol so if
you recall the classical definition of
pls it it involves an implicitly defined
graph simply implicitly defined by a
small circuit well in this definition I
just replace circuits with protocols
it's each node is associated with a
protocol that locally describes this
graph so if I fix an input and I run a
protocol as a node supposed to output a
description of the neighborhood of the
node in a graph so it's two pieces of
data a candidate successor node and an
integer label just the potential I call
it a potential associated with a node so
somehow the resulting graph needs to be
a dag and here's how I define it so
let's call it G that results on a fixed
input X and y you take x and y and you
run this protocol for each of the nodes
so you have two pieces of information
attached to each node and then you
define it there's no this edge from this
node to this node
if these node things this is it scan
successor and the potential decreases
along the edge so maybe the potential is
10 and here is 8 so if these two
conditions are hold candidate successor
and the potential decreases
I put an edge there so the potential
it's it's there to guarantee that the
resulting graph is really a dag because
you know when you follow edges that
potential needs to decrease so you never
create cycles it's so it's associated
with the note and I say I put an edge if
well the source node has a bigger part
of course gives not the attention of the
successor but potential of the node
that's right
so defines a dag seem tactically and so
we have to have some sinks and I say
that it's correct on this input if the
sinks correspond to feasible solutions
without in this graph just sink
okay so then the Associated label is a
feasible solution for the input X and y
so for any such problem Yuka asked
what's the most concise pls protocol
that solves it in this sense concise
here meaning the complexity measure is
something like this the cost of a
protocol I define as the log of the
number of notes you're using and the
communication cost of the protocols
let's say the maximum over all nodes of
the communication cost my notation for
the number of bits the protocol
communicates so that's the whole
definition if you instantiate this for a
monitor unclutch mix and game so then
this is what draws per approved
the log of the number of nodes so this
is the number of bits the protocol
communicates that's just my notation
okay so let me sketch one direction just
to kind of explore this definition a bit
here's a monitor circuit I want to
derive from a monotone circuit one of
these pls protocols and here's how what
I do i define this graph again GX comma
Y the nodes in my protocol is just the
gates and the input inputs and in order
to define this dag on top of this I'll
first say that a gate is feasible so let
me denote it by just highlighting it so
a highlighted gate is feasible if
Alice's input values that k2 true and
form evaluates to zero
by the way the top gate is always
feasible because the top gate company is
the function and you know monitor gotta
mix and game I'm given yes and no inputs
to the players and moreover feasibility
can be decided by a protocol that just
communicates two bits you know Alice
knows this value Bob nuts this value
they exchanged so me draw some notes
that are feasible and note that if an
input is feasible it exactly means that
it's a solution the model encouraged me
to think it means that two players
evaluate this positive variable
differently they've found a positive
difference if this happens there are
some unfeasible nodes and I'm just going
to define their potential as okay a
large number infinity and make them
point to the dock node
and then I'm going to observe that if
you're feasible as a node at least one
of your children needs to be feasible so
that's going to be your successor so
that's us that if you have a gate where
you have a positive difference Palace
has a yes gate book has a no gate it
must be that one of the incoming gates
also witnesses such a positive
difference both but you can figure out
the canonical successor one of the
feasible children so maybe like this
so that defines a dag and all this
relationship these edges can be
described by constant protocols that
communicate constantly many bits and the
sinks are naturally associated with
coordinates they they are the solutions
to monitor crushed abuse again it's
basically the whole proof it's really
nice the converse halt this is a
slightly more complicated so I'm not
going to go into it okay so unfeasible
infinities if you're feasible then the
height of the node so that you can have
these successes oh it's a topological
sort
okay so this is really nice but now
you're asking of course okay what is the
query complexity analogue if you have a
communication model well you can
canonically to find it and denote that
model by pls decision tree version and
the query world we're going to study as
in Roberts talk these search problems of
low certificate complexity which turns
out with our loss of generality they're
always of this form there are associated
with unsatisfiable k CSPs so f here is a
unsatisfiable case ESB case let's say a
constant
and as input you're given an assignment
to the underlying variables so it says a
boolean CSB so n variables its
unsatisfiable on so some constraints
need to be violated the problem is to
find one of them so it's a query
collects properly you can they ask what
is the decision tree complexity of such
a search problem turns out it captures
the tree like resolution size of
refuting F but here we're interesting
these dog like models so then we look at
again the query analog of pls so how
would you define something like this the
definition is exactly the same except
whenever I have mentioned a protocol
here I just instead have a decision tree
so each of the nodes are associated with
the decision tree you might as well just
have the communication protocol beep one
bit because you can have an additional
state keep track of the conversation so
far and just have one bit that says what
you answer then you just append the next
bit of the conversation I'm not sure I
follow at all it's the only obvious
communication game communications graph
with a protocol I'll define a new graph
where the vertices are original pairs
original vertex and partial conversation
so that's associated oh no there's no
unique path you can reach you there
could be many parts you can appeal s it
has a set of vertices in and a
communication protocol in every person
so I'm gonna define a new set of
vertices that's a pair original vertex
partial conversation of the protocol
yeah it's true you can just like normal
forms for these things so you can make
[Applause]
is basically like you query it's just
gonna be like querying at a vertex
what is this accessor yes there are
different normal forms well I want to
avoid this branching program connection
this is a lot weaker model than a
branching program so we can pre lower
about the resolution we can't free lower
vos a branching program that's a usual
pitfall so this you shouldn't think of
this as we start the route you follow a
unique path and output this there's the
more guarantees for any node that's
feasible you can trace down to a leaf
and find a solution which is a lot
stronger than just the kind of canonical
path yielding a solution
I think the model is going to look a lot
like maybe like changing the the goal
maybe maybe
yeah so there are different in the paper
I can actually use a different normal
form for the piece but I like this
conceptual approach that you just that
you don't think anything will just take
a Turing machine definition to replace
circuits with protocols the decision
trees canonical okay so it turns out
that this simply captures resolution
with
it's the same proof almost maybe I won't
give it in detail but roughly as you
could replace in this picture you know
think of the instead of a circuit I have
a resolution proof I must say I have the
leaves the constraints of the my formula
F and clause is where resolution derives
from two clauses logically sound and you
could derive one of these decision tree
pls versions out of a resolution proof
by just modifying your definition of
feasible now your feasible if clause in
a previous feasible I'm now fixing an
input there's only one input now this
boolean assignment if it was pulse if
I'd a resolution proof the top Klaus is
the contradictory clause it's always
feasible and if two clauses in by a
third and this is falsified under a
particular assignment must be at one of
it children are I decide feasibility
well to decide this condition you need
to query a number of bits of X
determined by the width of the clause
roughly why at least one direction of
this immediately holds solution
equal syntactic
okay so as in all Lifting theorems we
can hope to characterize the
communication version of this search
problem the original search problem
composed with a gadget and the main
theorem is that you do get an equality
but it's somewhat abstract in that if we
don't want to end up with more rational
circuit lower bounds so far we can start
with resolution lower bounds and get
some lower bounds for these lifted
search problems associated with
unsatisfiable csps but some creativity
is sometimes needed to find at last a
reduction from one of these types of
problems to monitor watchmakers tickets
previous work is given some reductions
okay we give more and in fact this kind
of a X or sat or more generally CSAT
function gives a kind of a simple
framework where there's a uniform word
way in which you can start with an
unsatisfiable ccs be so fix any set of
constraints if some CC SPS are hard to
refute in resolution can run through
this machinery and end up at a function
which is basically generalization of X
or sad and get an exponential lower bond
we lose something in the exponent
because of the size of the gadgets we
need to use so constant size Kadesh
would maybe yield
strictly exponential lower bounds that's
one yeah okay so there are constant
ok so I think I'm almost out of time I
just want to mention one direction like
this there was this pls communication
model and I just it gets such an obvious
question to ask
now what happens for other TF NB
subclasses pls is just one and
apparently in nobody sauces before as
far as I know so we thought about a
little bit done here's what we know
so we have P lesson which is circuit
okay there are other classes something
called continuous local search at the
very bottom functional P which was
communication analog is deterministic
protocols you could say this captures
formulas that's a Kaczmarek descent
characterization
other classes like the pigeonhole class
literally studied we don't know how to
prove explicit lower bounds for the
communication analog of this nor can we
find any models of computation that
would you know allow such a
characterization however by the punch
line there's a class called the parity
argument and for this class we can find
a mole of computation that captures it
does anybody have have a guess for it if
you don't haven't seen this before what
would be yeah so this was ninety five
eighty or something
why haven't people to explore this
characterizations you can also ask two
separate classes for example our main
theorem if you interpret in this
language XOR sad it's easy for span
programs over G of two it's sort of easy
for the communication class hard for pls
that's what the theorem says so it
implies an exponential separation -
Starro meaning no inclusion but very few
these separations are known so in query
go back see pretty much everything is
understood all the relative complexities
but for the communication complexity
very little sometimes separating two
classes is actually equivalent to
separating the monotone versions of the
associated models like it is the case
here so that's a huge project more
characterizations and more separations
thank you
[Applause]
so found everything he said it's better
than me there's like there's a lot of
uniform versions of history resolution
there was no query complexity somehow in
query complexity though it's very
similar you're doing well there's
certainly connections between t12 and
res log and pls I don't know if it's
exactly precisely put one of us very
close
and one of the how tight you can get the
lower bound would be will tell you don't
take all thank you the now equation but
to take just a linear number that come
out oh yes that's how you optimize
parameters yeah but at the moment the
lifting theorem is approved in such a
sloppy manner that we lose a lot there
already I think the best record at the
moment is cube root of n where n is the
number of input pieces are on Ross and I
listened we could maybe match that if we
worked hard but but proved a constant
size gadget lifting that would
the elevation
[Applause]